we make do we figure it out and I feel
like I've kind of figured out what works
for us well not anymore things are
getting ugly between Kristin Cavallari
and Jay Cutler in new court Doc's
obtained by et which the 33 year old
reality star filed on Wednesday
Christine claims that Jay is trying to
control their marital assets and is
preventing her from buying her own home
Kristin also claims in the docs that she
and Jay have been experiencing problems
in their marriage for the last several
years and that in the fall of 2019
things were so bad in the marriage that
she started looking for another home
when the outside like things are so
perfect and things are so great but
actually like they're not according to
the docs Kristen had a change of heart
after she and Jay attempted to salvage
the marriage well the docs say they
eventually realized their attempts to
make it work well wasn't working and new
a divorce was inevitable so in March
they started talking about how they
would divide up their assets and their
time with their three children since
April 7th the two have been splitting
their time with the kids alternating
every three days and when it's not their
time on with the kids
they've been leaving the house and
staying with friends sounds amicable
rates not so fast
Kristen alleges that Jay said he will
only release the money for her to buy a
new house if she agrees to his parenting
and custody plan and get this Kristen
thinks the former NFL pro rushed to file
his complaint as a way of punishing her
after she told him she was planning on
signing a contract to buy a house now
she's asking that the courts help her
access the funds so she can move forward
with the purchase as for why Kristen
wants new digs
she says she's worried that living under
the same roof with her ex will affect
the kids creating an unhealthy
environment and irreparable harm a kid's
my family they're my number one priority
they always will be in the docks Kristen
also claims Jay picks fights with her in
front of the kids and she fears the
situation will escalate Jay officially
filed for divorce on April 21st citing
irreconcilable differences Kristen's
filing came on April 24th citing marital
misconduct and irreconcilable
differences as the reason for the split
she also requested primary custody of
their kids the two announced their split
after 10 years together on Instagram at
the time a source told et the pair
struggled as their roles in the industry
have switched Jay retired and Kristen's
running various businesses it's been
interesting we've really completely
shifted roles so it's just been trying
to like navigate this new normal
Kristen and Jays problems were
documented on her reality show very
Cavallari when you were playing football
like literally I had to give up my whole
life and I feel like since I've gotten
really busy
I just haven't I don't feel that same
support from you and in 2018 she opened
up to et about how Jay was handling his
new normal after retiring from the NFL I
think honestly for us right now it's
more about just allowing him the time to
figure it out I mean he's 35 he's only
ever known football he doesn't really
know what he wants to do but I don't
want to badger him and push him and push
him I know he worked his ass off for so
many years so I'm just letting him enjoy
his free time is time
[Music]